chaque jour le même spectacle des
centaines de personnes attendent pour
obtenir leur passeport devant ce bureau
de service canada mais les délais
atteignent des sommets ça fait combien
de temps que vous attendez depuis 3h du
matin clément la semaine dernière elle
aurait été parmi les premiers dans la
file ces jours ci il faut arriver encore
plus tôt vous attendez depuis combien de
temps défini sa carrière soit ce groupe
a dormi ici ils ont pourtant fait leur
demande de passeport il ya plus de deux
mois combien de gens y avait devant vous
hier quand vous allez on en a compté
environ 140 je suis arrivé hier à 8
heures du matin à huit heures du matin 8
heures du matin plus de 24 heures
d'attentes donc tous ces voyageurs
anxieux et parfois détrempée parc d'ici
lundi certains se préparent à passer une
deuxième nuit à attendre ces trois
langues ça fait même aujourd'hui on peut
être là je pense on va quand un autre
jour jusqu'à demain ça va être comme 48
heures ici et tous ne voyage pas que
pour les vacances je dois aller voir mon
grand père en france qui est qui a
besoin de le voir maintenant moi je pars
pour le mariage de mes beaux parents
dont eux aussi sont en attente
apprennent ou est ce qu'on va pouvoir y
aller que le menace pas se lever pour
prendre la responsabilité de ce chaos
[Applaudissements]
la ministre responsable de service
canada doit affronter des critiques de
plus en plus dur
parce que
prévu que voyager serait populaire cet
été on comprend que les canadiens veut
voyager encore une fois mais la demande
est vraiment grand entrée prendra ça
alors pour tenter de réduire ces files
d'attentes service canada a engagé six
cents nouveaux employés depuis le début
de l'année et est en voie d'engager 600
autres mais est-ce que ce sera suffisant
force est de constater qu obtenir son
passeport est toujours une véritable
course à obstacles ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morin